I'm just freestyling I said I'm playing  one in this [ __ ] and everyone else is  just kind of like bots in my game so you  know I know I'm the [ __ ] but I know I  ain't [ __ ] yeah if I'm prepared to die  I'm prepared to kill I've lost many  times but I remain undefeated defeat is  a state of mind that said God forgives I  don't the Lord said vengeance is mine  I'm like yeah me too and now it's mine I  mean you're full of quotables it's  better to be  a warrior in a garden than a gardener  and a war they call them hands of stone  but he's got a head of stone as well and  I know this but  I can break blocks yeah I break Bricks  now you might copy the recipe but the  sauce ain't the same